Hugo Bernal ici s'est installé en face
de vous bonsoir Monsieur le Député la
France insoumise évidemment deux thèmes
comme d'habitude on commence par les
retraites peut-être évidemment je pense
que c'est un sujet du moment moi je
voudrais savoir Monsieur patriam je suis
sénateur comment vous assumez de porter
une réforme contre la majorité de
l'opinion des Français les sondages se
multiplient ce succèdent encore un
récemment publié dans l'humanité
aujourd'hui 65% des gens sont opposés
radicalement à cette réforme des
retraites et 65% sont d'ailleurs
favorables à une grève dure
reconductible pour mettre en échec cette
cette réforme est-ce que vous n'avez pas
l'impression de faire une réforme contre
le peuple alors
moi je suis parlementaire et en tant que
parlementaire j'essaye depuis de
nombreuses années de faire en sorte de
ne pas voter en fonction j'allais dire
de démagogue de la démagogie momentané
mais de l'intérêt général
aujourd'hui 65 % des gens sont opposés à
votre temps mais aujourd'hui ils sont
opposés mais ils étaient déjà opposés à
60 % lorsqu'il y a eu la réforme Fillon
aujourd'hui qui est-ce qui me remet en
cause la réforme client personne à
chaque fois qu'on a avancé dans la
réforme des retraites non mais personne
veut dire aujourd'hui vous exagérez
la suite de la réforme c'est la suivante
c'est 65 % bon donc vous avez la réponse
à votre question personne ne remet en
cause les réformes qui ont été faites y
compris par Monsieur Hollande que j'ai
soutenu personne pour que c'était
nécessaire si elle n'avait pas été faite
on serait dans le danger qui nous menace
aujourd'hui on aurait alors là x
milliards de déficits mais attendez
pourquoi je veux de la réforme
si je suis votre raisonnement si parce
que là parce que la donne la chance
dégringolerai demain mais très les
retraites à bas moi ce que je vous dis
quand je vous dis que les justes je vous
dis un 20 millions de retraités demain
notre système ne nous le permet plus et
tous les pays autour de nous l'ont
compris deuxième chose si vous pensez
aujourd'hui qu'on peut continuer à avoir
15 milliards de déficits par an parce
que c'est 15 milliards une année sur 10
ans c'est 150 milliards moi ce qui me
paraît aujourd'hui moi ce qui me paraît
juste aujourd'hui bonjour Aujourd'hui
c'est de ne pas laisser à mes enfants et
mes petits-enfants une France où ils
auraient une retraite de peau de chagrin
et où il y aurait 100 ou 200 ou 300 ou
500 milliards de dettes supplémentaires
c'est ça ma responsabilité c'est la
raison pour laquelle malgré le pignon
des Français aujourd'hui et bien je vais
voter ce texte alors pourquoi vous ne
votez pas des recettes supplémentaires
si vous ne voulez pas laisser des
retraites de peau de chagrin aux enfants
qui demain seront des adultes et des
futurs retraités parce que c'est votre
réforme qui va produire cela précisément
c'est-à-dire un allongement de la durée
de cotisation et le fait que les gens
partiront à la retraite avec s'ils
veulent partir au même âge
qu'aujourd'hui avec moins de retraite
mécaniquement ou sinon en moins bonne
santé parce que l'espérance de vie en
bonne santé elle ne s'améliore pas le
recul surtout vu l'état de l'hôpital
public donc je rejoins le débat sur la
question non non c'est le même débat la
question sur les supers profits on a
posé la question 15 milliards 15
milliards mais je voulais trouve tout de
suite d'accord c'est 56 milliards qui
ont été versés au CAC 40 en dividende
c'est 80 milliards d'évasion et de
fraude fiscales par an alors que vous
votre majorité non non c'est le même
sujet c'est de l'argent public qui
échappe
c'est de l'argent qui devrait revenir
dans les caisses de l'État s'ils y
étaient on se poserait pas de question
on sera en train de discuter est-ce
qu'on préfère 69
59 ans pardon ou 60 ans ou si on
pourrait descendre à 58 ou à 57 ans et
demi pour certaines professions voilà le
beau débat que nous pourrions avoir pour
le pays parce que peut-être que vous
avez une vision du retraité qui ne fait
rien qui ne sert à rien dans la société
qui est là en train de profiter moi
c'est pas la vision que j'ai du retraité
la personne qui est à la retraite
continue d'être utile pour son pays pour
de sa famille pour ses voisins et pour
tout le reste mais vous faites vous
faites tout le débat je veux bien me
parler
ça me va pas avoir le temps de répondre
moi j'essaie de vous répondre j'entends
bien votre discours sur l'état des super
profits et cetera j'entends bien cela
aujourd'hui j'ai ce que je voudrais vous
dire
le régime des retraites c'est un régime
par répartition qui fait que les
retraites des retraités sont financés
par les actifs et pas par des impôts
quelque chose soit clair donc voilà
alors quand vous avez dans la fonction
publique aujourd'hui ben moi d'actifs
que de retraités l'État met 30 milliards
robots et donc l'État met 30 milliards
au bout mais tout ça tout ça c'est 30
milliards qu'on ne met pas à côté pour
faire du développement économique de la
recherche de l'information
devriez pour t'entendre en baissant un
tout petit peu monsieur comme nous
parfait et qu'en baissant les charges et
les entreprises nous avons aujourd'hui
augmenter le dividendes vous le dites
jamais pas du tout ils ont des recettes
fiscales nettement supérieures à ce
qu'il y avait par le passé très net vous
le savez
rebonds du
covidiquement aujourd'hui mais pas du
tout c'est prouvé par a plus de
aujourd'hui comme il y a plus de gens
qui travaillent comme il y a plus de
richesse combien plus de bénéfices les
gens payent plus d'impôts plus de tactes
de cotisations non c'est pas vrai parce
qu'ils sont mal payés et que les petits
salaires sont exonérés de cotisations
sociales par un certain nombre de niches
fiscales c'est ça la réalité aujourd'hui
du fonctionnement économique c'est que
les bas salaire ne cotisent pas c'est
pour ça qu'il est urgent d'augmenter les
salaires mais pourquoi vous parlez pas
vous ne parlez pas du chômage mais je
vais vous en parler tout de suite il
faut augmenter les salaires augmenter
les salaires diminuer le temps de
travail dans la journée dans la semaine
et dans la vie augmenter les faut
augmenter les salaires et travailler
moins très bien exactement c'est vous
savez et vous savez comment on peut
faire ça et vous savez comment on peut
faire ça je vais vous citer un exemple
et vous vous voulez pas vous défendez ce
qui est capable c'est votre projet
politique parce que vous pensez le
ruissellement magique
vous êtes de gauche monsieur
contrairement à vous oui vous êtes de
gauche très bien bon moi je vous permets
pas de me juger je continue
pas à me juger moi je peux dire que je
n'ai pas de gauche qui est de droite
écoute-moi bien je vous dis que je suis
déçu social
expliquez-moi alors pourquoi si vous
êtes de gauche un pays voisin qui
s'appelle l'Espagne dans lequel le
gouvernement et socialiste et le
ministre communiste les affaires
sociales communistes vient de faire
passer en Espagne la retraite à 66 ans
et 3 mois sans de gauche hein comme vous
et voilà eux ils disent bah on est
raisonnable on veut assurer les
retraites on veut assurer l'équilibre on
veut assurer l'effort intergénérationnel
et on le fait expliquez-moi comment ces
gens de gauche et après on passera un
autre sujet mais je vois que ça vous
intéresse l'Espagne mais je crois qu'ils
sont en progrès par rapport à la
situation antérieure eux vont dans la
bonne direction
contrairement à vous vous voulez aller
plus loin vous voulez à 6 après demain
c'est très bien c'est votre projet
politique ça vous regardez à 43 ans et
demi de ne pas être dans un état social
comme la France ou les syndicats on on
luttait dur on conquis le fait qu'il y
ait des cotisations sociales que les
gens se payent leur retraite d'accord
c'est pas un cadeau de retraite c'est la
génération suivante qui paye la retraite
les gens se payent leur retraite oui les
gens globalement se payent leur retraite
les gens qui vivent aujourd'hui aussi
oui oui très bien c'est comment
fonctionne
exosquelette et en rien d'autre et que
c'est ça votre projet de société voilà
sauf qu'il y a des gens vous savez qui
réfléchissent propos d'interpréter ce
que j'ai dit par ailleurs vous avez la
tête vous avez l'attaque le sarcasme la
critique facile
je vous donne un Master 2 en la matière
c'est gentil maintenant
franchement ça n'est pas agréable on
passe pas par la pas par ce genre de de
en vous aviez encore un sujet le débat
est animé tant mieux mais pas de mise en
cause personnelle vous aviez un autre
sujet qui vous tient à coeur parce que
vous êtes un spécialiste à la commission
des lois exactement c'est la question de
la police judiciaire et de la réforme de
la police dans son intégralité par sa
départementalisation vous savez que deux
de vos collègues Nadine beluro et Jérôme
Durin viennent de rendre leur rapport
qui sont nos homologues on a fait la
même mission ici à l'Assemblée nationale
avec Marie guevenou et il plaide tout
comme moi pour un moratoire sur cette
réforme en disant ce n'est pas le moment
de réformer la police nationale en tout
cas tel que indiqué par Gérald Darmanin
nous avons des grandes échéances coupe
du monde de rugby Jeux Olympiques en
2024 ce n'est pas le moment déstabiliser
l'institution judiciaire il y a eu
encore aujourd'hui ce matin des
rassemblements devant tous les services
de la PJ du pays où les agents de la
police judiciaire dont les meilleurs
enquêteurs du pays
de la réforme c'est de départementaliser
c'est-à-dire qu'il y a un chef unique de
la police dans chaque département du
pays regroupant ceux qui font police aux
frontières ceux qui font police
judiciaire ceux qui font sécurité
publique ceux qui font renseignement
territorial tout ça un seul et unique
chef là aujourd'hui où nous avons des
directions différentes des emprises
territoriales différentes et des budgets
qui sont qui sont différents ma question
c'est est-ce que vous êtes favorable à
ce qu'il y ait un moratoire sur cette
réforme de la réorganisation de la
police et qu'on attend à après les Jeux
Olympiques à tout le moins quand bien
même on serait favorable au projet de
généralement
la réponse d'abord j'ai compris que vous
étiez aussi la toute réforme donc c'est
bien vous les paraformés vous voulez
mettre des impôts des taxes d'accord
mais pas de rien
aujourd'hui le constat a été fait qu'il
y a des doublons qu'il y a des paires de
substances qu'il y a des compléments qui
peuvent être fait aujourd'hui la police
fonctionne en silo de rapprocher les
deux aujourd'hui en respectant
l'identité de la PJ les moyens de la PJ
et les financements de la PJ à côté on
le respectant aujourd'hui en les faisant
travailler ensemble il s'agit de faire
quoi il s'agit de faire en sorte que la
petite qui gagne la délinquance qui
gagne aujourd'hui même la grande qui
gagne les petites villes les titres à
côté puisse mieux fonctionner parce que
les services fonctionneront mieux entre
eux ils font la moto d'ailleurs tous les
syndicats sont pas opposés aujourd'hui
les expériences qui ont été menées sur
le terrain dans certains départements
montrent que ça peut fonctionner demain
et le ministre a déjà dit qu'il
accepterait qu'il y a une direction
interdépartementale pour le faire mais
je pense qu'au moment c'est justement si
on fait cette réforme c'est pour la
faire avant les Jeux Olympiques et la
Coupe du monde pour que la police soit
plus efficace alors il est pas question
aujourd'hui ma réponse non au moratoire
non moratoires aujourd'hui je pense que
cette réforme il faut la faire il faut
la faire des mesures pas d'abord pour de
l'efficacité supplémentaire pour qu'ils
puissent d'efficacité que chacun dans
son métier soit bien soit bien fixé
rassurer et je crois que le ministre
monsieur Darmanin les a déjà rassuré sur
ce moyen donc je ne suis pas favorable à
ce moratoire mais en réalité la police
judiciaire fonctionne déjà admirablement
ce qu'on appelle police judiciaire la
direction centrale de la police
judiciaire un taux des explications
extraordinaires plus de 80% et déjà très
bien organisé sur l'eau du spectre il
manque de moyens il demande pas une
fondue
lisez le rapport de vos collègues
parlementaires il y a le rapport de
philippe Dominati aussi de la commission
des finances qui était très intéressant
qui est rentré au fond du sujet faut
qu'on sorte des punchlines on a mis le
sénateur Jérôme Dumas était farouchement
style depuis le début donc il allait pas
faire mais madame très bien elle était
pas du tout aussi la réforme et
d'ailleurs moi-même je suis pour
réformer la police nationale encore une
fois je vous ai dit à passer très fort
mais pour le coup
à la limite pour qui un chef unique de
la police sur police aux frontières
voies publiques renseignement
territoriale je comprends la logique
opérationnelle je l'admets et j'y suis
même favorable par contre je suis
favorable à ce qu'on sanctuarise la
police judiciaire et ce n'est pas vrai
qu'avec ce qu'a proposé le ministre avec
des mots et les sanctuariser non ce
n'est pas l'identité
on a croisé respecter un peu le travail
qui a été fait par les parlementaires
les auditions successives je respecte
surtout le travail causé par le ministre
voilà j'ai bien compris vous avez choisi
votre camp mais ça c'est c'est dommage
vous êtes avant tout parlementaire et
pas membre proche membre du gouvernement
c'est pas ce parlementaire qui soutient
le gouvernement pour qu'il réussisse
vous voulez que la France soit à genoux
moi je veux que la France réussisse
alors allons-y continuez comme ça je
veux pas que la France soit je vais lui
demander le gouvernement monsieur le
gouvernement retire sa réforme
si vous voulez vous payer le luxe
d'avoir en plus des manifestations de
policiers en plus de celle de tout le
reste du pays qu'on peut réforme des
retraites écoutez débrouillez-vous et
bien voilà c'est le mot de la fin merci
beaucoup
juste pression parce que c'est important
l'espérance de vie en bonne santé on a
vu des chiffres très récemment vous les
avez vu augmente ah bon bah tant mieux
tant mieux pour les gens c'est bien
aussi que voilà les gens je sais que
vous allez vous en féliciter merci
beaucoup Hugo Vern